You know, they, they,
they don't seem to fact check Joe Biden in Pennsylvania yesterday,
or the day before when he says I'm not against fracking. I'm like, well,
here's you on that same debate stage,
Joe saying that you'd eliminate fossil fuels that you said no new frack.
And here's you talking to another woman saying we're going to eliminate it all.
I mean, there's 50 clips of him saying exactly the opposite,
but because fracking is an important issue in Pennsylvania,
that is a swing state.
The media will literally run with the lie there where it's more of a
sensitive issue.
They'll run with exactly the opposite and pretend as though both of them are
true, just depending on who they're selling to. You know,
they're not fact checking. This is an egregious lie.
There's tape all over the place. Not one fact check called him out on it.
Not one social media site took him down for dishonesty.
They let him run the clip as though it's true.
[Inaudible].
Here for a minute because we're you guys, when I say you guys,
the Trump organization, the campaign, your dad,
what was the feeling when,
when it came out that it was Kamala because on one hand,
I think she's probably not as full say communist
Marxist, whatever that Bernie thing is. But as you just pointed out,
her voting record is pretty far left and she's an
authoritarian. You know, she, she did that line,
that line that I keep bringing up in the debate where they asked Biden,
you know, will you do an executive action on guns? And he said, well,
anything I would do would have to be constitutional,
which of course is the right answer.
And she looked at him and laughed in his face.
And now this is the person who is now his VP.
How did you guys feel about the choice?
You know, I, I lived with, I sort of thought, I think it's a great thing, right?
Cause you, you know where her record is. I mean,
she's literally left of Bernie in voting records.
She doesn't care about those sorts of things, as you've said, it's uh,
so she's also so disingenuous. She's just, you know,
you see that she's a phony.
And so it's just been pure ambition for her whole life. And you know, that's,
that's not a terrible trait,
but it is when you basically sell out all of your principles to get there.
So for us, I think it's actually a great choice,
but the media also agrees because the media also wanted her to be number one,
that's who they were pushing for from moment. Number one,
now she's terrible in this stage. She's not so warm.
She's just a terrible candidate, really. But for us,
I love it because everyone believes she's the one that's going to be in charge.
Uh, you know, it's sort of, you know, Joe Biden picking her after she,
now I got fact checked for this. They told me that I was,
they threw me off Instagram for this one because I said she called him a racist.
And she said to believe his sexual assault accusers. Cause again,
remember when someone accused of Joe Biden,
even though there's corroborating evidence much more.
So that doesn't count only those who accused Trump of something with much,
with no evidence with no corroboration, with all nonsense, you know,
that's to be believed. But when it happens to Joe Biden from a Senate staffer,
no, no, no nothing to see here.
But she did those things and you saw her absolutely demolish him on the debate
stage as it related to his racial decision and his,
then I get into that in the book a lot, but I said what?
She called him a racist. And she said to believe his sexual assault accusers.
So of course it gets fact-checked well, she didn't call him a racist,
but what do you mean? They go, well, she didn't say the words racist. I go.
Yeah. But she went on a five minute diatribe about how he supported busing,
how he partied with segregationist, how he did. I mean,
she didn't literally everything,
but no reasonable person in the world would assume that she meant anything other
than that. Yeah. I think Joe, Biden's a racist,
but they can fact check you as false. Uh, you know, they, they,
they don't seem to fact check Joe Biden in Pennsylvania yesterday or the day
before when he says I'm not against fracking. I'm like, well,
here's you on that same debate stage Joe saying that you'd eliminate fossil
fuels that you said no new fracking,
here's you talking to another woman saying we're going to eliminate it all.
I mean, there's 50 clips of him saying exactly the opposite,
but because fracking is an important issue in Pennsylvania,
that is a swing state.
The media will literally run with the lie there where it's more of a
sensitive issue.
They'll run with exactly the opposite and pretend as though both of them are
true, just depending on who they're selling to. They're not fact checking.
This is an egregious lie. There's tape all over the place.
Not one fact check called them out on it.
Not one social media site took him down for dishonesty.
They let him run the clip as though it's true. It's on his platform.
Just go look at his website. So again, part of the whole thing,
that's liberal privilege. You can have the best of all worlds.
It doesn't matter what the truth is. It doesn't matter.
We are going to sell to the American public,
whatever it is that they want to hear to be able to effectuate the change that
they want with just to put Joe Biden in office or whoever his puppet masters
really are.
So is the best example of that.
The exact video that Biden launched his campaign with,
which was the Charlottesville video.
And he didn't have basically saying your dad is supporting white supremacists
when, of course, and no matter how many times we talk about this,
it never makes it to mainstream media. The sentence before your dad said,
find people on both sides. And of course what he meant was of the statue debate,
completely condemned the KKK and the white supremacists and the neo-Nazis inner
though. But the media ran cover for Biden on that.
So in Biden's mind or whatever's left of it, he was just like, all right, well,
I can just keep going.
Why not? Why not run away that? I mean, they'll do whatever it takes to win.
It's no problem. Right? That's, that's what they're going to do by the way,
they brought that up at the DNC multiple times as though literally you're right,
the first sentence led up to it.
So it was clear before it wasn't like he made a mistake and recovered.
It was very clear to begin with.
They play one force of the clip and then they forget about the second sentence,
which was, and of course I'm condemning the white supremacists and the ne the,
the crazy people that were there because it wasn't all that,
but they run with it as though it's the gospel. I mean,
it's the same thing in the media.
They're still running Dave with Russia collusion.
There's still pretending like that's a real thing. Notice how there,
no one has any interest in like looking into comi and the FBI and Obama and
Biden himself unmasking us.
It's the first time we've had a non peaceful transition of power, a great,
great, great American tradition for 240 something years, nothing to see here,
folks.
Now it was a big deal for three years when they thought it worked the other way,
when it worked against Trump, when, when they could do that, I mean,
you see the testimony of these clowns. I mean, under oath,
they'd say X on CNN later that day, they say exactly the opposite because no,
one's going to hold them accountable.
They know it's not true because they're literally under oath saying the
opposite, but guess what? We get to CNN job. How about, you know,
the comi is in the, McCabe's something, these guys lied to Congress that, well,
you know, it's really bad. You said a lot of Congress, but nothing to see here,
I'd be in jail. If I lied to Congress,
they get paid big bucks to then be a CNN contributor. I mean,
they're rewarded for treason.
They're awarded for lying to the country and to the American people.
That's sort of what we're up against. And again,
that's why I took it upon myself to do this book when I had no intention to do
it because I've been a part of it. I've, you know,
if you didn't believe in the deep state,
if you didn't believe in sort of these big government things prior to 2016, I,
you know, I get it. If you don't. Now,
if you think that these people are truly just trying to represent you,
and they're not just taking care of themselves, you're out of your mind.
Look at what my father has tried to do. You know,
pulling troops out of Afghanistan,
ending these never ending Wars that our own generals can't even tell us why
we're there anymore. You know, they, they start leaking opposition research.
Trump is getting soft on Russia. What,
there's more sanctions on Russia than any,
than any administration in American history,
but they do that because they want to stay in endless Wars because they don't
care about sending your nice kids from middle America to go lose life and limb
abroad so they can keep the military industrial complex going.
And that's not just Democrats, that they're a big part of it,
but it's also the neo-cons and sort of the never Trump Republicans that hate
that he's getting out. You know, why?
Because they want to be on the board of Raytheon for $500,000 a year.
They'll do whatever it takes. They'll get their board seat.
They'll do that element of their friends, get rich,
sending our kids to die for something that we don't even know why we're there.
And it never ends.
Trump tries to pull out of these things and you literally have people in
Congress trying to literally stop him from doing it. Uh,
and it's so obvious. And yet again, nothing to see here, folks,
if you're looking for.
More honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.